hello believe nation today I'm going to
talk about seven tips to get more stuff
done during the day it's one of the most
common requests I get from entrepreneurs
is how do I manage my day how do I
manage my time I've got so much stuff
that I need to do how do I get it all
done in the day and I get it like
entrepreneurship is one of the hardest
things you're ever gonna do in your life
you're doing everything from being the
janitor to the CEO of the business and
so today I'm going to share the seven
things that I do to get more done during
my day that hopefully can help you and
your business as well number one is
create a schedule I find it super
helpful to have a schedule I live and
die by my Google Calendar which tells me
exactly what I need to do every single
day and putting the most important
things on the schedule first so the big
things I need to get done schedule them
in and what I try to do with my schedule
as well is chunk similar tasks together
I used to be the guy who prided myself
on answering email really quickly right
in being the guys like you send me an
email right away you get a response
now I barely check on the email we'll
talk about that later on in this video
but making sure that you are doing the
big things because so many people focus
on doing the small immediate things
putting out the fires that they have
zero time left to spend on the big
things to help them grow their business
so I put those in chunks in my schedule
every single week and the idea with
chunking is anything that you do
multiple times per day do once per day
anything you do multiple times per week
do once per week and so on so for
example making videos I do videos once a
week right Jason is here we're filming
together it's a Wednesday afternoon and
we'll do all the videos for the YouTube
channel for the week today and then I'll
send them off to Kristina and the team
and they'll edit them together and we'll
have videos for the week it's so much
easier to do it this way because I'm in
video mode we've got the camera set up
the lights set up the microphone set up
I got here right and so it's so much
easier to do one after another after
another for another I'm in the zone I'm
in the mode I mean video talking zone
right so it's easier to keep that going
from one video
next where I did one video every single
day there'd be so much backlog to be so
much time wasted in the setup when the
take down in just the switching cost an
emotional cost for me to jump from one
thing to another
that it's not very productive so batch
similar tasks together anything you do
more than once per week do it once per
week together
anything you do multiple times per day
do once per day together you'll be way
more productive and schedule it in
number two is working 90-minute chunks I
found this super helpful for me I will
book off 90 minutes to do one specific
task that's all the time I have for that
task and so if I'm looking at for
example on Monday I'll have a 90 minute
chunk of working on promoting my book
anything that has to do with phone in my
book whether it's you know reviewing
agreements or setting up interviews or
you know sending out emails or
responding to inquiries whatever it is I
have that 90 minutes to be able to do it
every Monday afternoon and then make
sure that I'm focused because if you
know you have all day to do something
you're not going to be working as hard
as you can you could find more time to
be able to be more productive when you
have a firm timeline on something and so
giving yourself a timeline I find 90
minutes is a good amount of time to get
into something some people use the
Pomodoro Technique which i think is 15
or 20 or 25 minutes whatever works for
you I find that just as I'm ramping up
it takes me 15 to 20 minutes to ramp up
into something and it a little bit more
time to get into it and then 90 is just
enough time to be super focused super
hardcore ready to go before I need a few
minutes break to move on to something
else and so experiment what works for
you but I found that 90 minute chunks of
working on one thing
dedicated tasks I have to get it done
and I'm not touching until next week so
I had to make sure I get it done today
in this timeslot really helps me stay
productive
so number three is set deadlines and
that ties into my last point whatever it
is that you want to get done when you
have a deadline set for yourself whether
it's within this 90 minute chunk or
whether it's by the end of the week or
whether its body in the month whatever
it is when you set a deadline for
something you're much more likely to
follow through and finish it and you
know what I'm talking about there's been
tons of things that there is no deadline
you know and you just let it float from
one week to the next week to the next
week to the next month and continues on
and so if a client is breathing down
your throat and say we need to have this
down by this day then you're gonna work
extra hard but if it's you yourself
setting deadlines for yourself you know
you often don't do it and you let it
lapse it's for all those people who are
the last-minute Crammers before an exam
comes up in school and university right
you see all those people cramming
last-minute because they didn't plan for
it but that deadline forces them to get
it done on time well if you don't set
deadlines for yourself or deadlines that
actually means something I II have
somebody else involved in it commit to
some way that you're gonna get it done
for that time it's something with real
teeth then you're much more likely to
follow through or if you don't set it
you're just gonna let things lag on lag
on lag on and your to-do list just grows
out of control so set deadlines
number four is build the team and as my
company has grown we have what 16 17
people in my business right now in TDS
we have around 10 people plus 4550
helpers who are involved in the business
as you grow your company your role your
specific impact gets smaller and smaller
and smaller because the collective of
what everybody brings is way more than
what you bring right and so at the start
you're doing everything you're you're
answering phones you're doing customer
service you're coding you're creating
the product you're delivering it you're
supporting it afterwards you're doing
everything but if you really want to
build something up you would really want
to leverage your time it's figuring out
what are you among the best in the world
that or what can you be among the best
in the world that and then everything
else you want to give to somebody else
and so one of the easiest places that
people gain time back is with accounting
right almost no entrepreneur likes
accounting and so given the bookkeeping
accounting over to somebody else frees
up your time to go do something else and
it doesn't have to be full time the
first guy I hired was for one hour a day
to do database work and he was able to
do it faster and better than I could
because I wasn't that great at it and so
he freed up an hour and a half to two
hours of my time every single day to
focus on building the business is doing
something bigger and so you may not have
budget to hire somebody full-time right
now but you don't need to right think
about what helps in your business like
you got to figure out what works find
something that works and when it works
and you got to figure out how do I
expand it and when you're expanding
there's a lot of tasks in there that you
shouldn't be doing and you won't be able
to grow and expand this quickly because
you're doing everything is not going to
be the answer and so finding the people
to offload the crap that you don't want
to deal with that they love dealing with
by the way right there's some people who
love accounting great give it to them
let them shine here because you're off
doing something amazing climbing that
mountain over there so building a team
allows you to get way more leverage out
of your time and other people's time to
reach the goals that you're after
number five is no phones this is maybe a
controversial one I don't have a phone I
don't have a cell phone I use a phone
but it's more of a tablet I don't have a
cell number I don't have a data package
there's no landline to be able to reach
me at I know in the extreme of most of
the world in that respect but I think at
least not having a phone number
published at least having time blocked
off where there's no phone is important
I see a phone number as other people's
agenda for my time because what happens
when somebody calls right you look at it
you may answer it if you answer it
you're guaranteed gonna be derailed from
it everywhere else you're doing right if
I'm spending 90 minutes to focus on my
book marketing and you call me and chew
up 15 minutes of it that's a big deal
for me because I've just lost 15 minutes
but more than that 15 minutes I've lost
a switching cost because to get back in
the zone of where I was before it's
gonna take me another half an hour and
so now you've taken out 45 minutes of my
time which is half of my time for a part
of my book every single week and so if
you value your schedule if you value
your time you feel like the work you're
doing is important then you can't afford
to have these interruptions a phone is
important it's a way to communicate I
will call people right and when I set up
phone calls it's always I'm calling that
person because I'm gonna be on time
because if somebody is 10 minutes late
and calling me that 10 minutes is not
going to be productive you just check in
social media or you know whatever it is
you're not actually productive so I am
always going to be calling you and we
have a set half hour time to talk about
things but having an incoming number I
am NOT a fan of now it may be important
for your business we have one for a
Toronto dance house people call but it
doesn't go to me I'm working on much
bigger things if you are everything in
your company then you might need to have
that but it's something that you quickly
want to be able to give to somebody else
to free up your time and make sure that
people aren't calling you or texting you
or you know interrupting your day
because your time needs to be valuable
if you don't set boundaries and protect
your time people are going to walk all
over you and you'll feel like you have
no time to do the things that you want
to do and so it may mean that you miss
out on some things I've missed out on
some important media opportunities are
important like last minute
things but I don't want to be in the
last-minute rush business I want to run
a no crisis business I don't want to be
reactionary constantly putting out fires
all over the place I want to focus on
building a business I want to focus on
doing the big things and I'm willing to
lose small projects that are rushed
last-minute and probably not the
greatest clients because I'm going after
something much much much bigger my time
is valuable
I respect my time you need to start
respecting yours if you want other
people to respect yours as well and so
no phone is one way that I do it
number six is no email this might be a
little less controversial but I used to
be again the guy that I said I prided
myself and responded quickly to email it
got to the point though was overwhelming
where I had so much email coming in then
I was just responding to emails all day
and I wasn't actually getting any work
done I'm sure you guys can relate where
your inbox just keeps filling up filling
up filling up and you could spend your
whole day just answering email and then
never actually jumping in on something
or you spend 10 minutes working on a
project and then an email comes in and
you're back to answering that I need to
jump back into that big project and
figure out where you were and you spend
15 minutes trying to figure out where
you work and another email comes in and
just in this cycle of not getting
anything meaningful or important done
all day long and that sucks as an
entrepreneur who's trying to build
something amazing and so what I ended up
doing was I went to a model of answering
emails twice a day in chunks 90 minute
chunks and then I cut that down to once
a day again in 90 minutes chunk so I had
90 minute chunk to check all my email
where I'm at now is I have a morning
segment where I'll check that the email
from important people it'll be my family
my team the media that I've dealt with
before or important partners or clients
and everybody else goes to a general
folder and the general folder I'll check
when they have time there is no 90
minute chunk there is no chunk of time
in my week where I'm checking the
general inbox it'll be when I'm in a
lineup trying to buy something when I'm
walking the Toronto dance salsa
whenever I have extra time I'll just
load it up and they'll answer an email
and they'll be offline because I'm not
connected to data or Wi-Fi anywhere and
so that's that means sometimes I may not
get back to somebody four five six days
sometimes that happens and so yes I will
lose business as a result right of being
slow but that time I'm using to focus on
bigger things and I get much more
leverage and much greater impact by
being able to go out and spend my time
those 90 minute chunks and something big
and powerful instead of answering
everybody's email instantly there's a
big value difference so I'd rather spend
my time on where there's high value and
again this could be a situation where if
you have a lot of email coming in and
it's some customers and you want to
provide great service that's something
that you as soon as possible give off to
somebody else I have multiple people on
my team who answer email for me I have
GT who deals with all of our authors I
have Sandra who sets up all of my
meetings with people and they are much
more responsive than I am by bringing
them on board back to the point above of
building a team or bringing them on
board I'm of the free up my time people
to go out and do the important things
and again that person can be part time
to start doesn't have to be a full-time
job
and number seven as cliche as it sounds
is do what you love if you want to be
productive you're gonna be way more
productive in doing the things that you
actually like doing right if you look at
your list and there's a bunch of crap on
there that you don't want to do and you
leave it to the next day and leave it to
the next day in that to-do list grows
out of control if you look at that huge
to-do list how many of the things on
there are things you actually look
forward to doing probably not that many
and that's kind of wrong right if your
to-do list every day is a bunch of crap
that you hate doing you don't look
forward to doing then something should
probably change in your business the
more you're doing work that you love
doing the more productive you're gonna
be not just feel B you're gonna get way
more stuff done and you guys know it
when you're in the zone when you're
feeling it you're able to get way more
done because you just love doing it you
love the process you love the work well
if you're forcing yourself to do it
because somebody told you to do it your
accountant told you to do it the
government told you to do it a customer
told you to do it the more that happens
the less productive you're gonna be and
the less quality work you're gonna
actually output and so not every day is
amazing and all day long you're just
doing amazing things you know you have
to be a little realistic about that too
but the more you're going to work and
you look at this piling up to-do list of
crap then you're not gonna have a lot of
success where you want to look at the
80/20 rule where you're spending as much
time possible doing the CEO stuff the
big-picture stuff the stuff that you
could be best in the world that and
eliminate automate or delegate the rest
away as soon as possible so you could
focus on the things that are most
important to your company so those are
my seven tips on how to get more stuff
done during the day I'd love to know
what you guys think what was your
favorite one let me know in the comments
below also did I miss something is there
an 8 9 10 that you want to add to the
list leave in the comments I'm looking
forward to hearing what you guys have to
say thank you guys so much for watching
between you to believe or whatever your
one where it is and I'll see you soon